[Music]
what happens
if you hold in your farts too long
we've all been taught that farting
loudly and proudly in public
is not okay so instead
we all try to keep our farts inside
no matter how much pain or discomfort
they cause
but could this social norm be
endangering our health how could you
die from holding in your farts
if you hold them long enough could they
disappear
or would they come out your mouth
instead
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you held in all your farts
on average a healthy person farts about
12 to 25 times a day resulting
in a release of 0.6 to 1.8
liters of intestinal gas that means
you could fill a one or two liter pot
bottle
with the amount of gas you produce each
day
that's a lot of gas to keep building up
inside you
if you never let any of it out would
your intestines
eventually explode
before we answer that let's talk about
where all that gas
comes from in the first place and no the
answer is not from
pulling my finger your body
creates intestinal gas as part of the
digestive process
this gas can come from the air you
swallow while
eating drinking or smoking it can also
be produced
when bacteria break down food in your
colon some foods
cause larger smellier amounts of gas
because they contain
sulfur these foods include things like
cauliflower
beans and dairy so you
probably shouldn't order that creamy
cauliflower bean soup
on a first date
[Music]
intestinal gas can either be released as
a burp
through the mouth or as a fart
through the anus while both are frowned
upon in public
farts are particularly offensive
but maybe we should worry less about
these social norms
and more about what holding in farts
does to our bodies
[Music]
as you fart gas moves from your
intestines
into your rectum and then leaves
through your anus when you hold in a
fart
you tighten your anal sphincter muscles
and
the pressure builds on the gas in your
digestive system
in the short term this can cause
immediate pain
bloating and heartburn the longer you
hold it in
the louder stinkier and more
embarrassing it will be
when it eventually finds its way out
and one way it could find its way out is
through your mouth
but it's not as gross as it sounds
if the gas is trapped in your body long
enough
it can be absorbed into your bloodstream
passed into your lungs and
eventually exhaled and
that's probably the best case scenario
of holding in
all your farts another possibility
is that you could develop swollen and
inflamed pouches
that form along your intestinal wall
this condition is known as
diverticulitis
it can lead to diarrhea fever and
bleeding from the rectum and
in case that doesn't sound fun enough if
your farts are held in
because something is blocking your colon
then
your colon will start to expand until it
pops
this only happens in rare situations
with
very ill patients but the idea is
still enough to make you think twice
about holding everything in
after all a fart is a natural bodily
function and
there shouldn't be such a negative
stigma around it
maybe we should just relax and let them
all out
at the same time
but that's a story for another
what if